a funny side note uh so Kubrick's uh uh
2001 Space Odyssey uh what do you think
about you know the fact that HAL 9000
was named after IBM I really don't think
it was I know there's I really don't
I've always could be more fake news it's
more fake news I have done I've like
researched this tried to find any
evidence and people talk to you know was
it really you know one letter it was one
letter one letter off right for people
don't know H is one letter off of I a is
one letter for b and then L is one
letter off of that was the I think
that's a solution found afterwards you
know but here's what I think it more was
I do think it's one of the early
demonstrations of evil AI yeah like can
be taught bad I could push back on that
because it's presented as evil in the
movie because it hurts the AI hurts
people but it's a really interesting
ethical question because the role of Hal
9000 is
um to carry out a successful mission
and so the question that is a human
question yes it's not an AI question at
what what price you humans wage war they
there they pay very heavy costs for
um
for for a vision for a goal of a future
that creates a better world and so
that's the question certainly in space
doctors ask that question all the time
under limited resources who do I
allocate my time and money and efforts I
agree I like I said I've spent a decade
talking about this question of AI ethics
right and that that it needs really
considerable not just attention because
otherwise it will mirror
everything we love and everything we
don't love and again and that's the
beauty in the eye of Beholder right
depending your culture and everything
else
with what you're doing and what you're
gonna do how do you think about it do
you think about the AI you're going to
develop as having guard rails dictated
by some of your beliefs or uh yeah for
sure so there's there's so many
interesting ways to do this the right
way and I don't think anyone has an
answer my I tend to believe that
transparency is really important so I
think some aspect of your work should be
open sourced
or at least have an open source
competitor that creates a kind of
forcing function for transparency of how
you do things so
um the other is I tend to believe maybe
it's because of the podcast and I've
just talked to a lot of people you
should know the people involved I agree
100 as opposed to hide behind a company
wall sometimes there's a pressure you
have a PR team you have to care for
investors and discussion and so on let's
protect let's surely not tweet not with
like and you form this bubble where you
have incredible Engineers doing
fascinating work and also doing work
that's
uh difficult complex human questions
being answered and we don't know about
any of them as a society and so we can't
really have that conversation even
though that conversation would be great
for hiring it would be great for
revealing the complexities of what the
company is facing so when the company
makes mistakes you understand that it
wasn't
malevolence or half-assedness and the
decision making is just a really hard
problem and so I think transparency is
just good for everybody
um and I mean in general just having a
lot of public conversations about this
is serious stuff it's uh
um that AI will have a transformative
impact on our society and it might do so
very very quickly through all kinds of
ways we're not expecting which is social
media recommendation systems they
they're at scale have impact on the way
we think on the way we consume news and
um the the the our growth like the kind
of stuff we consume to grow and learn
and become better human beings all of
that that's all Ai and then obviously
the the tools that run companies on
which we depend the infrastructure in
which we depend we need to know all
about those AI decisions and it's not as
simple as well we don't want the AI to
say
these specific set of bad things it's
unfortunately I don't believe it's
possible to it's not uh prevent
evil or uh bad things by creating a set
of cold mathematical rules yeah
unfortunately it's all fuzzy and gray
areas it's all giant mess it is I mean
you think about it Like a Knife a knife
can do good and a knife can do bad okay
you can't it's very hard it can't man
nice you can't ban knives and that this
is I think back it was probably 20 I
don't know 15 16. we did principles of
trust and transparency notice the word
transparency that belief that with AI it
should be explainable you should know
who taught it you should know the data
that went into training it you should
know who How It Was Written if it's
being used you have a right to know
these things and I I think those are
pretty to this day really powerful
principles to be followed right and and
part of it we ended up writing because
here we were when we're working on
particularly Healthcare like okay you
care who trained it in what and and
where it and that's I that's sort of
simple you know that comes to your mind
you're like yeah that makes a lot of
sense for something important like that
but it just didn't General
people won't trust the Technologies I
don't think unless they have
transparency into those things in the
end they won't really trust it